yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
you may know Margot Robbie best as
Leonardo DiCaprio's on-screen wife and
wolf of wallstreet all the Malick
wielding Harley Quinn and Suicide Squad
but before she hit the big time the
talented Australian actress made a crust
working at the fast food chain subway
thanks to a regular role in the Aussie
soap opera neighbours however Robbie
whose nickname is maggot was able to say
so long to serving sandwiches and hello
to future cinematic stardom
now to mark Robbie's latest big-screen
outing I put together seven crazy cool
facts you need to know about the trapeze
swinging tattoo giving actress Margot
Robbie is a mega sports fan and when she
moved from Australia to the US in 2011
to star on the TV drama series Pan Am
she captained a softball team she formed
with her co-stars and loved giving them
pep talks and painting their faces
before each game once in the States
Robbie also became part of an amateur
ice hockey team and her experience in
the rink could welcome in handy
on-screen as one of the movies that
Robbie has lined up to star in is a
biopic of former figure skater Tonya
Harding Robbie will also produce the
movie through her own production company
called lucky chap entertainment which he
set up with some of her housemates
including childhood friend and assistant
Sofia Kerr and Robbie's boyfriend
assistant director Tom acally who she
met while filming the world war two
movie sweet Francaise in 2013 while she
was filming The Legend of Tarzan in the
UK with Harry Potter director David
Yates and True Blood star Alexander
Skarsgard Robbie turn 24 years old and
celebrated her birthday and style by
holding a 24 hour long party the
carousing kicked off with champagne at
home at 9:00 a.m. continued with games
in London's Hyde Park and was followed
by burgers and bar hopping and even
included under the sea in western themed
costumes and it all came to a close with
more champagne back at home 24 hours
later after a night out partying with
friends in London Robbie got a call to
audition for wolf of Wall Street in New
York but when she turned up later that
day wearing jeans and flat boots to meet
the movies casting director Alan Lewis
Lewis sent her away to buy a tight dress
and super high heels when it came to the
audition itself Leonardo DiCaprio's
ad-libs almost threw Robbie off course
until she did
sided to take a risk and responded to
his improvise now get over here and kiss
me line by smacking him right in the
face DiCaprio and director Martin
Scorsese had a good laugh about it and
that dramatic performance sealed the
role for her actually Robbie seems to be
getting a bit of a rep for beating up
her co-stars in the war comedy-drama
whiskey-tango-foxtrot there's a scene
where Robbie's character playfully
punches Tina Fey and says were going out
tonight
according to Fey Robbie was so strong
from all the physical training she was
doing the Suicide Squad that her
on-camera punch left a huge bruise on
faze arm which lasted for several days
and then there's a sex scene that Robbie
filmed with Alexander Skarsgard for The
Legend of Tarzan which according to
skarsgård who plays Tarzan was the only
time he got injured during the whole
shoot apparently director David Yates
wanted the scene to have an animalistic
quality so is encouraging Robbie to beat
skarsgård up going back to wolf of wall
street martin scorsese gave Robbie the
option of wearing a robe or underwear
for that scene where she seduces
Leonardo DiCaprio's character wearing
nothing but stockings and high heels but
Robbie refused saying that her character
Naomi would be completely naked as her
body was her only form of currency in
that world still Robbie was in need of
some Dutch courage to film those sex
scenes so knocked back several shots of
tequila before hitting the set oh and by
the way many of those clingy outfits
that Robbie wore and her other scenes
actually belonged to the movies
oscar-winning costume designer Sandy
Powell who originally wore them in the
1990s if she wasn't an actress Robbie
says she'd like to be a trapeze artist
which isn't quite as weird as it might
sound at first because she actually has
experience in that particular area since
as growing up as a kid in Australia she
attended circus school and when she was
just eight years old she even got her
trapeze certificate and she took it up
again recently practicing in classes at
Santa Monica Pier during the shoot for
Suicide Squad Robbie really got into a
crazy Harley Quinn character setting up
her own tattoo parlor on set and inking
the word squad on her co-stars arms but
Robbie's push on for tattoos and
fascination with needles goes back
further a few years ago when she started
living in a shared house in London she
decided to make it a rule that everyone
living there had to get a tattoo then
when her housemate
now boyfriend Tom acally was getting his
tattoo done at the local tattoo parlor
Robbie persuaded him to let her take
over from the tattoo artist and after
The Legend of Tarzan finished filming a
friend of Robbie's gave her a tattoo gun
as a present which is what she used to
tattoo a journalist during an interview
as well as says Suicide Squad co-stars
so guys which are your favorite margot
robbie movies and what would you like to
see in a Harley Quinn spin-off film I'd
love to hear your thoughts in the
comments below if you enjoyed this video
do please like share and subscribe and
also check out my DC movies playlist
which has videos on Wonder Woman Suicide
Squad and more check out the links below
thanks for watching and see you next
time yippee-ki-yay movie lovers